hi there today we're looking at a bio
inspired by stable recurrent cell allows
for long lasting memory by Nikolov akava
damyang amst and aegean trio of the
University of liège this paper here is
not a paper that wants to push
state-of-the-art on anything it is a
paper that takes a concept from the
biological research on actual neurons
which is the bi-stability property and
tries to introduce it to recurrent
neural networks and on on toi data or
small data they show that this has the
interesting property that these
recurrent neural networks can then
remember important things for much much
longer than our current recurrent
architectures can do this I believe this
is a very interesting paper and it's a
nice you know refresher from the whole
state-of-the-art number pushing papers
so dive in with me to explore this if
you like content like this also consider
subscribing if you aren't and sharing it
out and leaving a like in the comment if
you have any sort of comments all right
they they basically say recurrent neural
networks provide state-of-the-art
performance in a wide variety of tasks
that will require memory which is true
right so we have these recurrent neural
networks and what the recurrent neural
networks do is they're basically so a
classic recurrent neural network go
something like this
there is a hidden state at time step T
and there is a sequence of inputs that
you have to work with so we'll call them
X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 and so on and then at
some point you have to provide an output
this could be at every single time step
or sometimes it's just at the end you
have to provide an output Y so for
example this here could be a piece of
text and you need to decide whether or
not that piece of text maybe it's an
email whether or not that's spam this
could be a time series of a patient in
an ICU and you need to decide whether or
not to give some medication to the
patient so the
occasions of this are very wide and any
sort of series data will do so there's
this hidden state and at each time step
this hidden state is updated to a new
hidden state so this call did call this
h0 it's updated to a new hidden state by
incorporating the input so somehow the
input X and the previous hidden state
are made into a new hidden state and
then the next input is taken in and by
using this hidden state a new hidden
state is made and so on so one property
here is that the newest hidden state
always only depends on the previous
hidden state and it doesn't really
directly depend on like the hidden state
to before itself it only depends on the
hidden state right before itself and the
input that corresponds to it so this is
the information for the other important
property here is that these connections
that make a hidden state into the next
hidden state and also that incorporate
input they're always the same so these
for these functions here that
incorporate the input they're always the
same in each time step so the parameters
are shared between them and the same the
same goes for the D functions here that
transform one hidden state into the next
hidden state of course this there is a
joint function between the two that
actually produces the next state and
state so these weights are all shared
and it for each time step and that's
what makes the network recurrent so we
call the single time step here we call
that a recurrent cell and the question
now is how do you construct a recurrent
cell usually recurrent neural networks
they run into this problem of either
gradient explosion or vanishing
gradients because usually this here if
you are into neural networks you know
this this is a weight matrix multiplied
by the previous hidden state and if you
just multiply the same weight matrix
over and over and over again it pretty
much depends on the same
the value of that weight matrix if the
top singular value is higher than 1 then
this signal is going to explode and if
it's lower than 1 the signal is going to
fade over time and there's pretty much
nothing you can do so classic Oren ends
have been have looked like this right
here so the next hidden state is a
nonlinear function G and G can be some
non-linearity like a sigmoid or a
hyperbolic tangent but it's a known it's
a function of the current input and the
last hidden state by simply matrix
multiplying these two things by some
weight matrices and then adding them up
so that's what we've just looked at now
this is problematic as I said because of
the vanishing or exploding gradients and
therefore people have come up with
methods to solve this and you might know
things like L STM's and gr use that are
used to solve this now these cells here
are much more complicated than the
standard cell that we saw here but they
also are much more effective because
they don't have this vanishing or
exploding gradient problems their
promise is that they can remember things
for a longer because they allow the
gradient to flow without these problems
during back propagation now how does one
of these look in this paper they mainly
look at the G are you the gated
recurrent unit which is a simpler
version of the LST and the LST M is
slightly more complex but the principles
are the same so they look at the G are
you right here what does the G are you
do these are the formulas for the GI G
are you and we're going to try to
deconstruct these formulas so as you can
see the inputs are the same inputs are
going to be this points input this time
steps input and the last hidden state
okay those are all the quantities that
we need and we need to output somehow
the next hidden state okay
the last hidden state is then used to
predict the why by the way in all of
these cases so first we need to
calculate two things called Z and R and
both of them are the same they're
multiplying these two things by weight
matrices and then running them through a
sigmoid non-linearity okay let's do that
let's say we have X sorry the last
hidden state here and we have X T here
so first we're going to calculate the Z
T and the RT from that now every one of
these arrows right here is a
multiplication by a weight matrix so
every one of these arrows is
transforming the input and let's also
let's join this into a sigmoid node and
that gives you Z T and let's join these
into a sigmoid that gives you our T okay
so far so good
now we need to combine all of this in
this last line right here so you can see
that the Z thing here sort of acts as a
switch so Z is the result of a sigmoid
and therefore it's between 0 and 1 and
here this is the the Hadamard product
this is the element-wise product between
vectors which sort of means this is like
a gating this is like a switch if it's 1
it selects this quantity and if it's 0
it selects the quantity over here and of
course it can be between 0 and 1 but
that those are ready this the ends of
the spectrum so Z is a switch that
selects between the last hidden States
so let's draw that right here so the
last hidden state goes here and is one
of the options of the output right so
and the option is given by Z so Z T
let's how do we draw a switch like this
maybe
so ZT is responsible for module
this switch right here okay this gives
you the next hidden state you see
ZT modulates that switch so HT is a one
possibility that the switch can select
what's the other possibility the other
possibility is this quantity right here
which is a hyperbolic tangent of
whatever that is
so that is combined of X so let's go
from the from the back right here tan H
what's the input to the tan H it's two
things first of all the the X is an
input to the tan H so we can draw
directly a line from here the X
modulated every arrow as you might
remember is mod is can be a function
you know the whole arrows are functions
like this arrow right here is not a
function it's just an arrow
maybe that's confusing you get what I
mean
and the next thing is our x the hidden
the last hidden state or the last hidden
state motive modulated by this matrix so
R is an R is acting as another gate R
can be again between 0 and 1 because
it's the result of a sigmoid so this
hidden state will also go here it will
be modulated running out of colors here
be modulated by our here as a sort of
gate so R can either close or open this
gate right here and then that's fed into
the tan H so it's rather complicated set
up as you can see right here so let's
analyze this first of all the hidden
state is either the last hidden state or
it is something new and that's modulated
by this Z right here and Z is calculated
from the hidden state and the current
input okay so this allows the cell to
basically look at the hidden state is
sort of the information
what happened so far and the current
input is the new information that it
gets from the sequence and it sort of
gets to look at these two things and
decides do I even want to update my
hidden state if not I can just select
this path right here and then nothing
happens to the hidden State the next
hidden State will be exactly the same as
the last hidden State if it decides if
it thinks wow this new thing in the
sequence that's actually important I
should remember that right because
remember these the task of the network
sometimes is to remember things from
this sequence I think we drew this over
here so if this is an email and we want
to detect whether it's spam then this
word in the sequence right here might be
really important because it would say
something like gold like by gold these
two things might be by gold and you need
to remember that in the hidden state
because the only way that information
from X is going to flow to Y is through
the hidden States so you would want at
this point you would want to remember
this input in the hidden state so you
would actually want to update the hidden
state and then this here might be not as
important so you might want to say I
don't wanna I don't wanna I still want
my hidden state to be the old hidden
state okay so Z is that gate that allows
us to do this if we decide to update the
hidden state then what do we do again if
we decide to update the hidden state we
can we can we will incorporate the new
input but we will we can also decide to
mix that how to mix that new input with
the old hidden state okay so if we
decide to update the hidden state we
don't simply discard the old hidden
state because the old hidden state will
still have a path to the two to be sort
of still there
to be remembered but it's a longer path
and it needs to go through this thing
here and through this thing here so this
thing here decides which of the old
hidden state
pass through so at each you can see
right here this is a element-wise
product this R is going to be between
zero and one at each point in the vector
so at each point in the vector the R
decides is this worth remembering or not
okay and if it's not worth remembering
then this is going to be zero and that
that position of the old hidden state is
going to be zero and then that's going
to be forgotten and that's the
opportunity for for the hidden state to
incorporate new information because then
there's a it can delete this old
information and it can incorporate the
new input and that will result in on
this path on the new hidden State okay
so there's two major things first we can
decide whether or not to even
incorporate new information that's
achieved by the Z gate and then we can
decide which parts of the old hidden
state if we want to update it which
parts to forget that's the or gate and
how to update it is then basically a
result of the weight matrix that's
associated with this function right here
all right so that's the gated recurrent
unit and it works a lot better than the
classic RN ends so having said that they
now turn to this property of neuronal
bi-stability
that happens in actual neurons so this
here is sort of a model of a neuron with
this property now forget everything we
said about gr use we're just going to
look at this right now what happens in
the neuron usually is you have this is a
single neuron you have input synapses
from other neurons so these are
connections coming from other neurons in
into you
they are accumulated right here usually
they are just in a classic model of a
neuron they're just summed up you would
sum up all these all these input signals
and then you decide you'd run it through
like a step function so if the sum of
all the things is smaller than a
particular
hold the output would be just nothing
and if it's higher than a particular
threshold then the output of the neuron
would be sort of a firing of the neuron
this can be wait and whatnot but in this
case it's just a function of the inputs
and that gives you your input signal so
this is like this is it this is your
input signal to the neuron now there is
this property right here that makes it
interesting the signal goes out here and
is integrated this is an integrator and
that's going to be in the output signal
but there's this Greek disconnection
this back connection right here and that
means that the signal that comes out at
time step T is going to be fed back into
the signal and actually added to the
signal before itself and sort of self
modulating right the signal comes out is
sent back is added to this input and
then sent through again and this here is
just an integrator that's integrating
everything that's happening so if you if
you look a bit closer you'll see that
there is a minus here so it's actually
not added it's subtracted and there is
an F here which means that this is a
nonlinear function now if this weren't a
nonlinear function we can just sort of
try or let's say this is a monotonic
function we can sort of try to estimate
what happens if all of this right here
is very high you know it's a high number
big number this will be a big number
then this sum will be a big number this
output will be a big number what happens
is this here will be a big number this
is monotonic so it will also be a big
number and the that means it will
subtract that big number so that means
when whenever the neuron is going to to
be very excited this feedback would
actually push it back now when it is not
very excited so when it's a very low
number very negatively excited then the
feedback
would work in the exact opposite
direction this will be very negative
this will be very negative and this here
would push it towards the positive so
this neuron somehow self stabilizes
overtime to this to the zero point right
here
and that's simply if this F is a is the
identity function right now so you can
sort of see how this property works now
we'll make it a bit more complicated in
that we'll assume that this F here is
not the identity function but let's say
they have it somewhere but this right
here so the F F of the post is this here
it's we post minus alpha tan H of repost
Horace is this the entire F yes that's
this this thing right here if this is
the case if this is that this if this is
the signal minus the tan H then
something very very very interesting it
happens and that that's depending on
this alpha right here in that if this
alpha is between if the Alpha is between
zero and one then we simply have our
monotonic function so here you can see
how big we post this so how big the
output signal is here that's the
experiment we made before and here you
can see what the feedback signal is okay
or the integrator the integrated signal
maybe this is in the wrong place and
maybe F is just minus the tan H I'm not
sure but in any case the way they build
it after in the gru it's pretty explicit
so this is the thing we said before
namely if if the signal is very high
then this signal here will be high as
well and because it's subtracted right
here it's it's going to push the signal
back
towards zero again if this is looks
lower than zero then this thing here
will also be lower than zero and because
it's subtracted it's going to push the
signal towards zero so this thing here
is the stable point it will always push
it back towards zero however if we
change the function and we change change
just the parameter alpha to be one point
five a very different thing happens that
you can see right here then it turns out
if your output signal is very is very
high the same thing happens is going to
put me push back but if your output
signal is between zero and this point
right here there is a regime where
actually even though the output signal
is positive you will be pushed towards
this point right here and therefore
there is there are these two stable
points right now and the stable point
basically means if you deviate if the
signal deviates from it it's going to be
pushed back towards that point and you
can see these two stable points they're
not at zero they're actually at at these
two points here and that's pretty
interesting because um that means you
can potentially remember things with the
cell right an output signal of zero is
basically not informative but here you
can be in either the state here or in
the state here and the little little
perturbations will still keep you in
that state so you could potentially be
in this state right here as an output
and the cell will just keep updating
itself and be stable and always output
that signal right here and then you
could go ahead and if you can provide
some huge input signal right here you
could potentially throw this over to the
other side over this hill and then it
would stabilize at this point so this is
sort of a way to remember things within
these biological cells pretty cool now
this here is a non filled circle that
means it's an unstable point it's
technically stay
is stable in the sense that if you're
exactly at zero you will remain at zero
but if you perturb even a little bit you
will go oh if you perturb a bit you will
go away from it okay I hope this sort of
property is right is clear and why this
is so fascinating because we can use
this these this fact that the stable
points are not at zero and are more than
just one stable point for remembering
things and they're now trying to fill
this into the gated recurrent unit so
they call this the by stable recurrent
cell BRC and the formulas are these
right here a little smaller come on
can't zoom any more okay it looks almost
the same as the GRU so the formulas are
these this and this so let's analyze the
differences to the GRU the first most
striking difference is that a lot of
weight matrices here have become single
numbers so or single vectors this here
used to be a make weight matrix and this
used to be a matrix multiplication and
you'll see this sort of throughout
whenever the last hidden state is
incorporated into these things then
you'll see that it is no longer a weight
matrix but is in fact a in a product
with a vector a element-wise product and
that has a reason namely what they want
to model is individual neurons so on a
biological level and neuron can only
feed back onto itself if there is a
layer of neurons right here
they can only each feed back onto
themselves whereas in a recurrent neural
network my hidden vector my hidden state
is a vector and if I transform this into
the next hidden state or any quantity
let's say I transform this H into this R
right here and this R is a vector to
then any interaction is possible so any
sell any entry in the vector here can
influence any other vector because
there's a big weight matrix in the
middle they want to leave this away they
want to model this as close as possible
to actual layers of neurons and
therefore they say okay the input X can
you know be distributed to all the
neurons because technically the input
comes from some other neurons down here
and they can all have connections to
these neurons but these feedbacks we
only really observe them in individual
neuron this feedback cycle so that's why
they model these recurrent wait products
by just element-wise products with
vectors and then the second difference
you again see that there is this switch
right here this C switch and the C
switch is like before it's a sigmoid
with where combined the the output and
the previous hidden state there's
nothing new here so this switch is the
same the cell has the possibility of
letting in new information or just
ignoring the new current information the
XT the second thing is here and this is
the same as well right the tan H this is
a combination of the new information
it's in case we want to let in the new
information of the new information and
you need to decide what things of the
old information to forget or remember
now the difference here is in this a so
this a used to be
again this sigmoid of the combination
and now it's just slightly different it
used to be sigmoid now it's 1 plus tan H
this is a very very slight modification
its tan H because tan H is between minus
1 and 1 instead of 0 and 1 like the
sigmoid and the 1 plus makes it such
that this is between 0 & 2 and we've
seen before that this critical behavior
there is 2
to these functions when it's between
zero and one this behaves like a classic
gated recurrent unit like a classic GRU
but when it's between one and two then
you have that exact behavior that we saw
before of the bi-stability
okay so depending on what the a is if
the a is zero to one
it's a classic cell and if the a is one
to two it's a bi-stable cell and the
network can decide by itself what it
wants to do because here it has it can
actually learn how to do that alright so
this is the only change the only change
really apart from it only being
individual neurons feeding back on
themselves is that now this is no longer
between 0 & 1 with sigmoid this is now
between 0 & 2 because it's 1 plus the
tan H very simple change but the effect
of this is pretty pretty cool so they do
some theories like a schematic drawing
of this if this a is between 0 & 1 again
you have this stable state that's at 0
but it spits between 1 & 2 you have two
stable States at two nonzero points and
again this we already saw this but now
this is for I believe this this
recurrent cell this by modal recurrent
cell not for the neuron itself and here
they give an example of what happens
when you run this particular signal this
particular time series through a cell
like this while fixing the C and the a
parameters so now the C until a
parameters are learned they're just
fixed and you see what happens now as
you can see the the blue should be a
classic the classic behavior so in this
blue case what happens you see right
here this C is moderately low so we saw
the C is the switch of whether to leave
in old information or take up new
information if
it's low it means we want to take up new
information this is reasonably low and
that's why when the signal goes up here
the blue line goes up as well and when
the signal goes down the blue line goes
down again and so on so the blue line
pretty straightforwardly
follows the signal right here okay now
in contrast to this the red line is over
this threshold so a is fixed at 1.5 C is
still at 0.2 so again when this line
goes up then this line goes up but
because this is near a this stable point
if it goes down again it doesn't appear
to go down enough it sort of remembers
that state it was in it doesn't go down
with the signal only now that it goes
down even further it's over this
threshold so we were in this situation
now and the first bump down was only
like two here and that pushed it up
again but now it jumps over here because
the signal is even lower and then the
cell sort of switches to another state
as you can see here it goes down but
then this bump here is not enough to
bring it up again so it kind of remains
in this state so you can see the it sort
of remembers the input and small
deviations or small changes in signal
don't manage to throw it away from that
only larger things only it needs to go
vary the signal needs to go very much
down in order for it to change the state
so that's pretty cool that this is
remembering behavior and now remember in
the actual implementation these C and a
parameters this C and this a right here
aren't fixed
they are also determined by the cell
itself and therefore the cell can decide
by itself when it wants to remember
things how hard it wants to remember
things and so on so we're going to check
this out in an actual implementation so
there's this one last modification they
make where they say okay they tried this
and it
doesn't really work because it works
sometimes but there is this issue of
these neurons connecting only back on
themselves which really makes the model
much less powerful than a classic
recurrent cell it's closer to biology
but it's much less powerful and there is
this property they say of
neuromodulation where technically in
real neurons the one neuron here could
influence another neuron by modulating
these a and C parameters ok these a and
C parameters this is called neuro
modulation
so there are interconnections between
the neurons that influence how much
other neurons remember and forget things
so they decide let's model that and lo
and behold we're now back to having
weight matrices right here so this this
is sort of they say this is a not really
a super biologically plausible way of
implementing neuromodulation but it sort
of it's an easier way and it brings us
closer to the G back to the gru and yeah
so now the only difference to the GRU is
that the fact that here there was a
sigmoid now it's a 1 plus tan h ok I
find this that's pretty cool so now also
the only difference here is this
property of bi-stability this is the
only difference and now we can actually
compare so let's compare they first give
they do these sort of benchmarks which
are they're pretty pretty neat so they
have this first benchmark where it's the
copy first input benchmark I'm having
some trouble here moving this paper
around with my fingers so the copy first
input benchmark is simply a time series
in this benchmark the network is
presented with a one dimensional time
series of T time steps and the each
entry is a is a random number
after receiving the last time step the
network output value should approximate
the very very first input step okay so
all the network needs to do is remember
the first thing it sees and that's that
should be learn about right that should
be learn about because you can so you
can it's not specified whether the zero
is hidden state the initial hidden state
is given into the network but
technically it doesn't matter because it
can just learn whatever that is I can
learn to have a designated bit in this
hidden state so this hidden state is of
a size 100 I believe one designated bit
in the hidden state of whether it has
already encountered the first thing or
not if it has not encountered it means
that it's at the first time step
therefore it should incorporate the new
information into the hidden state and if
and also set this bit and then for each
subsequent step you can see I've already
set this bit and it can simply close
that gate that makes it incorporate new
information so it should be able to
carry this information all the way to
the end by simply always closing that
gate after the first step and what
happens in this so as you can see when
the result is all the results up here so
this is after three so they train it for
300,000 gradient descent iterations and
you can see that when these time steps
when the series are pretty small the LST
m's or the gr use tend to perform well
but you can see that these BRC is they
don't tend to perform poorly they're
just performing worse right it's zero
it's still the 0.01 regime or something
like this of error however when you go
up to like 300 steps then you can see
the gr use and the l STM's they start to
fail because they are not made
explicitly to remember for that long
they don't have this by stability
property whereas now
these things Excel you can see they're
still pretty low and at 600 steps these
things completely fail they completely
forget the input so and the NBR see at
least is still able to remember the
first thing pretty pretty well and yeah
so the second one is no this is the
first experiment still the copy input
benchmark you can see right here that
even at this 3 at this 100 thing where
the GRE you still learns it it learns it
much much later than the BRC which
learns it pretty fast
only here when the when it's only 5 when
it's series are only five steps long
does the GRU slightly outperform the BRC
so the general notion here is that these
classic cells are more powerful in like
classic tasks whereas these things are
shining whenever these things fail
because they can't remember things for
very long so they're not these new cells
are not state-of-the-art yet possibly
there are still some modifications to be
made we've had a pretty long history of
optimizing gr use and LS TMS they
haven't always worked so well as they do
now because we kinda know how to handle
them and I expect if these cells here
take off especially these in VR C then
with time we'll be as proficient at
handling them and they will probably
become on par or even outperform the
LSTs or gr use on every day like on all
the tasks and then be especially good on
tasks where you have to remember things
but for now they're outperformed by LS
DMS and gr use ok so the second thing is
a more interesting experiment the
denoising benchmark where they say the
the copy input benchmark is interesting
as a means to highlight the memorization
capacity of the recurrent neural network
but it does not tackle its ability to
successfully exploit complex
relationships between different elements
of
input signal to predict the output they
have a new benchmark in the denoising
benchmark the network is presented with
a two dimensional time series of T time
steps five different time steps are
sampled uniformly with okay and are
communicated in the network okay I'll
just tell you what what's going on so
this new time series is two-dimensional
in the lower dimension you simply have a
bunch of random numbers like five eight
to nine
actually these are numbers sampled from
a uniform Gaussian or so so they're not
actually 5 8 2 & 9 but you can imagine
it like this 5 a 2 9 3 4 0 2 and so on
and in the second dimension you have a
negative 1 I believe almost anywhere and
then at some points you have a 1
negative 1 again and then you have a 1
and a negative 1 again and at last point
of the sequence you'll have a 0 and so
the zero is simply a marker that it's
the end of the sequence what the network
needs to do is it needs to output all
the elements so the output of the
network should be in this case should be
9 4 so all the elements where there was
a 1 in order ok so it remember what it
needs to learn it needs to learn to
every time it sees a 1 in the second
dimension it needs to take the first
dimension put it somehow into the hidden
state and then carry that hidden state
forward and sees a 1 again it needs to
take the second thing also put it into
the hidden site but not override the
first thing it put into the hidden state
like if it were to just realize I need
to put this into the hidden state then
it would almost surely override the
previous information so it needs to be
able to say I've already kind of in my H
is going to be a vector of a hundred
dimensions it needs to be able to say
well I've already stored a bunch of
stuff in that part
of the vector maybe I should store that
thing here over here this is fairly
complex things to remember and
technically gr use and Dallas teams are
able to do it but as we'll see they're
not as much the results are in this
table where you can clearly see that
whenever the N so the N the N is a
parameter that is how far how far in
this direction are these ones so when n
is zero the ones can be anywhere but
when n here is like five that means that
the last five ones surely don't contain
a 1 that means only the first whatever
Add L minus L minus 5 contained the 1 so
the higher this number n is the harder
the task because you're learning signal
is way way further away from the from
what's when you get the output so you
can see when the N is low then the gr
use and the L STM's they perform pretty
well but also these cells perform pretty
well they're just not performing as well
however when the task gets harder and
you actually need to learn a sparse
signal over a long period of time where
in between you don't get any signal the
GR use and the LS TMS fail while the
brcs would still be able to learn these
kinds of things so that's that's fairly
cool now it's if from a researchers
perspective I wonder if they just first
tried this task you know as I described
it and then they discovered like ah crap
they can still do it and like ok how can
we make it such that there is a
difference ok let's actually make the
task harder like this and then they did
that I wonder if they always have the
idea with the end here or just introduce
this after after it they they fail to
produce a difference in the first place
I'm not sure but they have they have
another benchmark but they basically
show that these cells are actually good
can incorporates this information can
reason about what they
need to remember and whatnot and in the
end they also have this sequential em
nest where they just feed an M nested
digit by digit and at the end I think
the the what the output of the neural
network needs to be the class of the of
the M this digit and again here they
have a parameter called n black which
means that so they have an M this digit
it's like a three
they unroll it to a single vector right
they feed this one by one into the
recurrent Network and then after that
they attach a certain number of just
empty pixels black pixel and after that
the network needs to predict the Y you
can see if they ask the network the
class of the digit immediately after
it's done then the gr use and the lsdm
perform fairly well as do the BR C's but
if you attach a whole bunch of these
black pixels remember an amnesty it has
some seven sorry 784 may be entries so
attaching 300 black pixels is quite
significant in in terms of the length of
these sequences and then the gr use and
the L STM's
they can't learn they can't learn to
ignore these things because the learning
signal is just too far away right here
but these things they can because they
can exploit this by stability property
and remember things again I I wonder how
this came to be
it seems pretty funny but the last thing
they do is they investigate what happens
in their cells and this I feel is the
most interesting part and they do this
on this denoising benchmark so the task
we've looked at before where you need to
remember five randomly selected numbers
that are indicated by the second
dimension here they show a sequence
where the five numbers occur at 3,100
246 at 300 and at 376 so these are the
five positions where the sequence
indicates that the networks
remember the thing in the first
dimension and an output they analyzed
two things they analyzed the proportion
of bi-stable neurons so basically they
analyzed this out these a quantities and
they analyzed how many of the neurons in
the lair have an a that's higher than
one which means that they are in this by
stable mode and also they analyze what's
the average value of C so see if you
remember if this is high it means it
doesn't let in new information and if
this is low it means it lets in new
information if we first look at the C
you can see that every single time when
the second dimension indicates that this
is one of the inputs to remember this
the network drops immediately drops the
C values the different colors here are
different layers they build they have a
recurrent network has multiple layers of
these cells as as usual in the recurrent
neural networks so this C as you can see
it goes up pretty quickly but and then
as soon as one of these inputs appear
the C drops which basically means that
the network realizes it now must let in
the new information and then it
immediately shoots back up makes it seem
like so the network says okay as long as
so all of these inputs here they have
the negative one in the second dimension
right so it recognizes it says there's
no reason for me to incorporate that
information it's not important and as
soon as the second input comes it
immediately shoots down again now you
can see this here is the last layer of
the network the highest layer so sort of
the highest abstractive information and
you can see that from input to input
this value of C gets higher and higher
and these spikes as they go down but
they go down to a higher and higher
point which you know is is the fact that
it recognizes it needs to let in new
information but it lets in less and less
new information the more things it needs
to remember so not only does it
recognize weight
need to remember this it also recognizes
but I probably shouldn't shouldn't you
know completely forget what I had
previously because I it is important for
me to remember these previous things so
that's a pretty cool demonstration the
fact that these go down at the input and
the fact that generally they go up every
time after a new input is incorporated
into the hidden state this basically
this shows that the or this is a pretty
good indication that what they're saying
is really happening right okay the
second thing shows almost the same it
shows how many of these neurons are
actually in there by stable mode and you
can also see right here that especially
in the last layer you can see that the
number of neurons in the by stable mode
goes up and up and up and up after each
of these steps and these spikes here
corresponds to always the points where
they have to let in new information okay
cool so I find the event is to be pretty
cool and I find this last experiment to
be the coolest where they can actually
show look here there's a pretty good
indication that the thing we we built
does what we say it does they also
actually have a proof here of the
bi-stability when this a is higher than
one i won't go through this right here
but if you want you can look at that I'm
excited to see what happens with these
kinds of architectures in the future
because it seems to be a pretty minor
modification and maybe with a little bit
of more modification or if we sort of
just tune this a little bit and kind of
figure out what we have to do to make
these things actually compete with the
classic gr use and LS TMS in regimes
where a long memory isn't necessary I
feel this could be a you know kind of a
standard building block in the recurrent
neural network toolkit even though it's
been sort of outperform
by Transformers in previous years all
right that was it for me and I hope you
had fun with this paper and invite you
to check it out and bye bye